[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe this time I'll be lucky maybe this
time he'll stir
[Music]
maybe this time for the first time love
won't hurry
[Music]
I'll be home at last
not a loser anymore like the last time
and the time before everybody
love so win her
so nobody loved me
I call singing my first language our
currency is being open and being opened
and available to our emotions if you're
closed off as a person how are you gonna
be a performer to get out there and you
know show love or show agony or show
despair listen make sure I'm listening
to the person I'm up there on stage with
because if you're truly listening then
that'll force you to be in the moment
yes the strong get some more while weak
once pain empty pockets don't ever make
the grave
[Music]
hell [ __ ] public health but god bless
the child less got his own yes God is Oh
[Music]
evolution is very important to me as an
artist usually if I'm scared of it I
know I have to do it I will be a better
actress a better artist doesn't
necessarily mean that I will succeed but
will I have grown as a result
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you